>> CLERON: Hi, my name is Mike Cleron. I'm
an engineer on the Android Development Team.
Android is an open software platform for mobile
development. It is intended to be a complete
stack that includes everything from the operating
system through middle ware and up through
applications. In the next few minutes, I'm
going to be introducing you to an overview
of the architecture of the Android platform.
And I'm also going to talk about some of the
key principles that are underlying its design.
If I'm going to talk about architecture, we
need to start with a diagram covered with
a lot of little boxes and this is ours. Our
architecture, we’re going to start at the
bottom work up. Our architecture is based
on the Linux 2.6 Kernel. We use the Linux
Kernel as our hardware abstraction layer.
So, if you are an OEM trying to bring up Android
on a new device, the first thing you do is
bring up Linux and get all your drivers in
place. The reason we’re using Linux is because
it provides a proven driver model in a lot
of cases existing drivers. It also provides
memory management, process management, a security
model, networking, a lot of core operating
system infrastructures that are robust and
have been proven over time. The next level
up is our native libraries. Everything that
you see here in green is written in C and
C plus, plus. It’s at this level where a
lot of the core power of the Android platform
comes from. I'm just going to go through and
describe what some of these components are.
I'm going to start with the surface manager.
The surface manager is responsible for composing
different drawings surfaces onto the screen.
So it’s the surface manager that’s responsible
for taking different windows that are owned
by different applications that are running
in different processes and all drawing at
different times and making sure the pixels
end up on the screen when they’re supposed
to. Below that we have two boxes, OpenGL/ES
and SGL and these two make up the core of
our graphics libraries. OpenGL/ES is a 3D
library. We have a software implementation
that is hardware acceleratable if the device
has a 3D chip on it. The SGL graphics are
for 2D graphics and that is what most of our
application drawing is based on. One interesting
thing about the Android graphics platform
is that you can combine 3D and 2D graphics
in the same application. Moving over, we have
the Media Framework. The Media Framework was
provided by PacketVideo, one of the members
of the open handset alliance and that contains
all of the codex that make up the core of
the media experience. So, in there you’ll
find IMPEG 4, H.264, MP3, AAC, all the audio
and video codex you need to build a rich media
experience. We use Free Type to render our
fonts. We have an implementation of SQLite,
we use that as the core of most of our data
storage. We have WebKit which is the open
source browser engine, that’s what we’re
using as a core of our browser. It’s the
same browser that’s powering Safari from
Apple and we’d made some, we’ve worked
with that engine to make it render well on
small screens and on mobile devices. Next
is The Android Runtime. And the main component
in the Android Runtime is the Dalvik Virtual
Machine. The Android Runtime was designed
specifically for Android to meet the needs
of running in an embedded environment where
you have limited battery, limited memory,
limited CPU. The Dalvik Virtual Machine runs
something called dex files, D-E-X. And these
are bytecodes that are the results of converting
at build time .Class and .JAR Files. So, these
files when they are converted to .dex, become
a much more efficient bytecode that can run
very well on small processors. They use memory
very efficiently. The data structures are
designed to be shared across processes whenever
possible. And it uses a highly CPU optimized
bytecode interpreter. The end result of that
is that it’s possible to have multiple instances
of the Dalvik Virtual Machine running on the
device at the same time, one in each of several
processes and we'll see why that’s important
a little bit later on. The next level up from
that is the Core Libraries. This is in blue,
meaning that it’s written in the Java programming
language. And the Core library contains all
of the collection classes, utilities, IO,
all the utilities and tools that you’ve
come to expected to use. Moving up again,
we now have the Application Framework. This
is all written in a Java programming language
and the application framework is the toolkit
that all applications use. These applications
include the ones that come with a phone like
the home application, or the phone application.
It includes applications written by Google,
and it includes applications that will be
written by you. So, all applications use the
same framework and the same APIs. Again, I'm
going to go through and talk about what some
of the main components are in this layer,
in the Application Framework. The activity
manager is what manages the life cycle of
applications. It also maintains a common backstack
so that applications that are running in different
processes can have a smoothly integrated navigation
experience. Next down from that is the package
manager. The package manager is what keeps
track of which applications are installed
on your device. So, if you download new applications
over the air or otherwise install applications,
it's the package manager that’s responsible
for keeping track of what you have and what
the capabilities of each of your applications
are. The window manager manages Windows. It’s
mostly a Java programming language abstraction
on top of lower level services that are provided
by the surface manager. The telephony manager
contains the APIs that we use to build the
phone application that’s central to the
phone experience. Content providers are a
unique piece of the Android platform. That’s
a framework that allows applications to share
their data with other applications. We use
that in our contacts application so that all
of the information in contacts, phone numbers,
addresses, names is available to any application
that wants to make use of them. And other
applications can use that facility as well
to share data. The resource manager is what
we use to store local iStrings, bitmaps, layout
file descriptions, all of the external parts
of an application that aren’t code. I'm
just going to touch lightly on the remaining
four boxes, view system, location manager,
notification manager and XMPP service. The
view system contains things like buttons and
lists, all the building blocks of the UI.
It also handles things like event dispatching,
layout, drawing. Location manager, notification
manager and XMPP service are some APIs that
I think will allow developers to create really
innovative and exciting applications. And
the final layer on top is Applications. This
is where all the applications get written.
It includes the home application, the contacts
application, the browser, your applications.
And everything at this layer is, again, using
the same application framework provided by
the layers below. Now, if you’re going to
write an application, the first step is to
decompose it into the components that are
supported by the Android platform. Here are
the four major ones. We have activity, intent
receiver, service, and content provider. An
activity is essentially just a piece of UI
typically corresponding to one screen. So
if you think of something like the mail application,
that would be decomposed into maybe three
major activities, something that lists your
mail, something that shows you what an individual
mail message and a compose screen to put together
an outgoing email. An intent receiver is something
different. An intent receiver is a way for
which your application to register some code
that won’t be running until it’s triggered
by some external event. And the set of external
events that triggers your code is open and
extensible. So you can write some code and
through XML, register it to be woken up and
run when something happens, when the network,
the network activities established or at a
certain time or when the phone rings or whatever
trigger makes sense for your application.
The next major component is a service. A service
is a task that doesn’t have any UI, that’s
long lived, that’s running in the background.
A good example is a music player. You may
start playing some music from an activity,
from a piece of UI, but once the music is
playing, you'd want it to keep playing even
if you’re navigating to other parts of the
user experience. So the code that’s actually
running through the playlist playing songs
would be a service, that’s running in the
background. You can connect to it later if
you want to from an activity or some other
component by binding to the service and sending
messages like “skip to the next” or “rewind.”
The last component is a content provider and,
again, that’s a component that allows you
to share some of your data with other processes
and other applications. Now, any application
can store data in whatever may--way it makes
sense for that application. They can store
it in the files. They can store it in our
super light database, whatever makes sense.
But if they want to make that data available
as part of the platform so that other applications
can make use of it, then the content provider
is the solution for that and we've used that
for the context database that comes with the
Android platform so that any application can
make use of the information in context. Android
was designed at a fundamental level to encourage
reusing and replacing components. I have an
example here that shows how that works. On
the left, there are four applications that
might want to pick a photo for some reason.
So the home application might want to pick
it for wallpaper. Contacts might want to pick
a person’s face to associate with their
contact card. Gmail or MMS, you might want
to have a photo that you sent to someone in
an outgoing message. Now, an Android for these
applications to make use of the service of
taking a photo, they first need to make a
request. So the client component makes a request
for specific action. In this case, I’m illustrating
that with a talk balloon and the Gmail application
is requesting that it picks a photo. So the
talk balloon is actually representation of
a formal class in our system called an intent.
What the system does when a request is made
is it looks at all of the installed components
and it finds the best available component
that knows how to do whatever was asked for.
In this case, let’s say that the system
finds the built-in photo gallery. Now, what
happens is the Gmail application is now connected
to the photo gallery. When the user in Gmails
wanted to pick a photo, he will be taken to
the photo gallery and the photo gallery will
fulfill whatever was asked for in the intent.
What makes this interesting is that the picking
of the matching component is late bound, it's
done very late and so you can swap software
components at any time. So let’s say you
didn’t like the built-in photo gallery and
you wanted to replace it with one that went
online to find a richer or bigger set of photos.
You can replace our built-in photo gallery
with one that say goes out to Picasso or whatever
your favorite online photo site is. Once you’ve
done that, then any of the applications on
the left will now use the new and better component
on the right to fulfill the task of picking
a photo. And at any time, a new application
can come along and make use of existing functionality.
So if you’re writing a blogger application,
you don’t have to worry about writing a
photo picker yourself. You can just rely on
whichever one the user has configured to be
their preferred photo picking application.
This becomes really important because in Android,
it’s not just about picking photos, virtually
any task has an intent in the middle. If the
user is going from point A to point B, there’s
an intent in the middle and each of those
intents is an opportunity to reuse a component
or to replace a component. So we have intents
for going home which means you can replace
a home application. Or we have an intent for
sending an email which means you can replace
the mail application. All of these are opportunities
for replacing and reusing components. If you’re
interested in finding out more about Android,
I encourage you to visit the developer site
and download the SDK. In the SDK, you’ll
find a lot more documentation and sample code
and you’ll also be able to try building
applications of your own. There’s also a
developer group that you can join to find
out more information and I also encourage
you to check back frequently because we’ll
be posting updates to the SDK as the platform
matures. Thank you for watching.